The first thing that happens when
we create a new notebook is that
the context realizes something has
changed in the objects within it namely,
there's a new object.
The context therefore sends the
NSManagedObjectContextObjectsDidChangeN-
otification with a new
object as a payload.
And as FetchedResultsController
receives the notification and
sends a delegate message to
CoreDataTableViewController,
which in turn tells
the TableView to update.
So, there's no magic.
It's just the MVC, delegate, and
notifications doing their job.
Make sure you understand this, and
then if you haven't already, add a
similar button to the node's controller.
It's exactly the same thing.